one time was they walk on protein
folding well the question is how poor
teen could fold to one structure instead
of many structure so this when this work
it was kind of a it was something with
it was declared as a major problem
though to me it was to me it was not
such a big deal o puzzle but it was
clearly something impressive a the other
part which i kind of consider more
important like understanding how enzyme
works figured out how to model enzymes I
felt this is break so when it was done
but it's not necessarily was not
necessarily shared by the referees or
the community so there is this gap
between me thinking that something
important to asking whether it will make
him question so add quite many problems
that I was extremely happy to solve and
then of course unhappy from the response
of the referees but although all there
were several major accomplishments that
I felt that this is nice